Speaker 1: Let's go next to Frumpies from
Chicago. Frumpies, you are on the air.
Speaker 2: Hold on, David, I'll take
your time. Hello, can you hear me OK?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: OK, so I've been having a conversation
Speaker 1: and you're cut you're cutting out
already. So we had we had the first cut out.
So let's see if we can get to the let's
see if you can start over here. Have you
cut out? You're having conversations.
Speaker 2: OK, yeah, I've been I've
been having conversations with, like some
cynical Republicans about this, talk about
Democrats want to want to raise taxes on the
rich and all this. And the cynicism comes from
these Republicans who respond to me and say,
well, why would these politicians vote to raise
taxes on themselves? And I kind of struggled to
respond to that because I'm sure there's examples
of times they've done it in the past. But I just
don't know how to respond to that type of cynical
attitude towards this these bills.
Speaker 1: So there's a couple there's a
couple of different things, a couple of different
things. First of all, the the taxes. So let's
see how to break this down in pieces. First of
all, the tax increases that are being proposed
are actually for people whose salaries are higher
than that of most of our elected officials.
You know, members of the House and Senate make one
hundred and seventy five thousand dollars a year.
I think if you're in leadership, it's more like
215 or something like that. Biden is talking
about this is going to hit people making over four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars as a couple or
four hundred thousand individually or whatever the
case may be. Now, the counter might be well, a lot
of these people have more income than that because
they also have whatever business they had before
entering the House or Senate or they have a spouse
like Nancy Pelosi's spouse makes a lot of money,
all of this sort of stuff. So so the first part is
it's not always the case that these things would
hit them, number one. Number two, why would
an elected official do something that doesn't
benefit them financially? Well, if they actually
cared more about what was good for the country
and what their constituents want, it is, after
all, representative democracy. We don't elect
these people to do what's good for them. We elect
them to do what's good for us and to represent our
views. So it's an insanely it's not even cynical,
but it's the whole point here is they're being
elected to do the will of the people. That's
why they might pass a bill that would increase
their own taxes. And if they're not willing to do
it, they should be removed from their positions.
Speaker 2: Right, I agree. And then just one
more comment on that thing that, you know,
raising taxes bill that you just
referenced. Yes. That includes like
investment income and capital gains and such a..
Speaker 1: Well, my understanding is that it is
talking about earned income like wages. So when
it talks about five million dollar earners or
whatever, my understanding is that's not talking
about capital gains. A little bit of the problem,
honestly, Frumpies, is that a lot of this
stuff has not yet we've not yet seen like
pen to paper and exactly the way it's all going
to work. It's just kind of bullet points. And
that's why I'm keeping my analysis, macroeconomic
in general, until we actually know exactly how
all of these things are going to be set up.
Speaker 2: OK, David, thank you for your comments.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. All right. Frumpies
from Chicago, very much. Appreciate that